hello in this video we're going to think
about techniques for subtracting three
digit numbers so let's say we wanted to
figure out what 357 minus
156 is
pause this video and see if you can
somehow figure this out and i you don't
have to be able to because we're going
to walk work through it together but it
doesn't hurt to try a little bit
all right now let's do it together and
one way to think about it is what if we
were to break up the 156 into its
different place values so we view it as
100 and 50 and 6 so then this could be
rewritten as 357
minus 100
minus 50
minus 50 that's 5 10s right there and
then minus 6.
now does this help us pause this video
and see if you can figure out what this
would be
well many of you probably said all right
if i have
357 and if i ever take away 100 well
then i'm going to be left with 257
and then if i take 50 away from that
250 away from 205
well i have five tens here and i'm going
to take away 5 10. so i'm going to be
left with 0 tens i'm going to be left
with
and then if i took 207 and i subtracted
6 from that
so 207 minus 6 that of course is going
to be equal to 201. i just took away
those six ones and i had seven ones on
top of the two hundreds before to get us
to 201 so this is one
very good technique for being able to
subtract numbers and it doesn't just
apply to three digit numbers you can do
this with many digit numbers but there's
other things that you could be doing you
could for example try to adjust the
numbers to make the subtraction easier
for example you could say hey wouldn't
it be nice if instead of subtracting 156
i only had to subtract 150
and there is a way that you could do
that as long as whatever you add or
subtract to one of these numbers you do
to the other then the difference will be
the same so there is a situation where
you subtract 6 from both of these
numbers before you try to find the
difference so let me
write this out so let's say you wanted
to subtract
from
both
what would this be well 357 minus six
well we're just going to take six ones
away from the seven ones here so it's
going to be 351
minus
156 minus six well that just gets us to
and this might be for many of y'all a
little bit more straightforward to
compute you might realize all right if i
have three hundreds and i take away one
of those hundreds i get two hundreds
if i have five tens and if i take away
those five tens i'm going to be left
with zero tens and if i have one one and
if i take away
no ones i'm still going to have one one
or you could say
look 300 minus 100 is 200 51 minus 50 is
just one so that was pretty helpful
another technique is to
instead of going 150 you might say well
what if i wanted to subtract 160
well in that situation you could add 4
to both of these numbers
add
four
to
both
what would happen then pause this video
and try to figure that out
well what's 357 plus four 357 plus three
gets us to 360 plus another one gets us
to 361
and if i add 4 to 156 that is 160 and
since i added 4 to both i added the same
amount to both the difference is going
to be the same
and so if you look through this 300
minus 100 is 200 it's left and then 61
minus 60 that gets us to
that gets us to 201 and what i just kind
of did in my head if i wanted to write
it out we could say this is the same
thing as 361
minus 100
minus 100 and i could
break it out completely like i did up
here or i could break it out partially i
could just break out the hundreds place
and then break out the 60.
so minus 60. i guess you could view that
as i broke out the tens and i didn't
write the ones but you can see 361 minus
100 would be 261 and then you take 60
away from that once again you would be
left with
201. so the big takeaway here is there's
many different ways to approach
subtraction with however many digits you
have and this just gets you a glimpse of
different methods and some will be more
convenient in different situations
depending on what numbers you are
dealing with